would you take your hands at your
pockets for me hey what's up
a deadly officer involves shooting in
Tennessee where video allegedly shows a
suspect walk under crime scene tape and
open fire
November 12th in the Madison
neighborhood of Nashville Tennessee
officers with the Metropolitan Nashville
Police Department received a call just
after two o'clock in the morning for a
non-life-threatening shooting when they
arrived police found a 32 year old
victim on the scene he was taken to the
hospital but wouldn't give officers
details about the incident meanwhile
mnpd officers roped off the area with
crime scene tape as they worked to
gather evidence for processing who's
that
strike this way who's that
who's that about 33 minutes after the
initial call Body camera video shows a
suspect walking toward police with his
hands in his pockets
hey can you put your take your hands out
your pockets for me officers call for
the man to stop but he walks under the
crime scene tape hey what's up
after that officials say the suspect
allegedly started shooting shots fired
shots fired we need more officers over
here right now code three three officers
Sergeant John Tim Sergeant Leonard
spivecchia and officer John robish all
returned fire the suspect whose identity
has not yet been released died on the
scene right now investigators are
working to determine whether he was
involved in the initial shooting
from here the Tennessee Bureau of
Investigation is conducting a use of
force investigation the Davidson County
District Attorney's office and the
Metropolitan Nashville police department
will also conduct investigations for the
latest development in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie